WITH NO LIMIT ON HIS POWER.
>> Laura: JOINING ME NOW AS
HIS PERSONAL ATTORNEY AND SOL
WISENBERG AT FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR.
THE   THEY ARE ALSO SAYING THE M
THE   THEY ARE ALSO SAYING THE E
THE   THEY ARE ALSO SAYING THE L
THE   THEY ARE ALSO SAYING THE R
REPORT MAKES THE REQUEST MOVE.
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION?
DOES CONGRESS HAVE ANY RIGHT TO
THIS INFORMATION?
>> LET ME SAY SOMETHING ABOUT
HIS RESPONSE THAT THE PRESIDENT
IS A TYRANT AND ABOVE THE LAW.
THIS IS A LEGAL MENTOR RANDOM.
IT IS VERY WELL THOUGHT OUT AND
VERY WELL WRITTEN AND OBVIOUSLY
HE MAKES THE POINT OF EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE BUT IT GOES WAY BEYOND
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE.
IT MAKES A VERY IMPORTANT POINT,
I WOULD'VE ADDED NANCY PELOSI
STATEMENT LAST WEEK THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IS THE SUPERIOR
BRAND BECAUSE THAT IS THE WAY
THEY ARE ACTING.
THEY'VE ISSUED NOT JUST ONE
HEARING BUT DISLIKES HEARINGS SO
IT HAS TO BE SEEN IN THE CONTEXT
OF HEARINGS.
THEY HAVE ALREADY ISSUED
HUNDREDS OF SUBPOENAS LOOKING
FOR POSSIBLY A MILLION DOCUMENTS
OR MORE.
WE HAVE JERRY NADLER, ADAM
SCHEFTER, THEY ARE ALL LIKE
DAYTIME TELEVISION AND THE
REALITY IS THIS IS A TREMENDOUS
BURDEN ON THE EXECUTIVE MAY LAW
HAS A WAY TO DEAL WITH IT.
THERE ARE CASES THAT SAY THAT
LEGISLATIVE POWER IS THERE, BUT
I CAN'T BE USED FOR ANY
PERMISSIVE PURPOSE.
AND THERE ARE SUBPOENAS AND
INFORMATION REQUESTS AND THEY
DON'T CITE A SINGLE PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THEY ARE PURSUING.
NOT ONLY THAT, THEY ARE TAKING
OVER AN EXECUTIVE BRANCH
FUNCTION.
THEY ARE AFRAID TO CALL THIS
IMPEACHMENT HEARING.
THIS IS OVERSIGHT.
YOU DON'T ISSUE HUNDREDS OF
SUBPOENAS.
>> Laura: ARE YOU SAYING THAT
IF THIS WERE ACTUALLY IN
IMPEACHMENT PROCEEDINGS THEN YOU
WOULDN'T HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
THESE?
>> THEY HAVE TO GENERATE THEIR
OWN INFORMATION.
THEY CAN'T BE JUST REDOING THAT
AND IF THEY WERE IN GOOD FAITH
THEY WOULD READ THROUGH THE
MUELLER REPORT AND THEY WOULD
SAY WE NOW HAVE ALL THIS
INFORMATION.
WE HAVE TEN MORE QUESTIONS OR 15
MORE QUESTIONS.
>> Laura: THEY ARE DOING A
DRAMATIC READING OF THE WHOLE
THING.
>> SEVERAL FEDERAL CASES MAKE IT
CLEAR THAT IF YOU'RE GOING TO
IMPOSE ON THE EXECUTIVE THAT HAS
TO BE TAILORED AND IT HAS TO BE
NARROW.
IT CAN'T BE OVERLY INTRUSIVE.
THIS IS ALL OF THOSE THINGS.
IT IS BOREDOM SOME.
IT HAS MULTIPLIED BY SIX.
>> Laura: THIS IS EVEN TALK
ABOUT THE CASE AND THE D.C.
DISTRICT COURT INVOLVING THE
PRESIDENT AND HIS FINANCIAL
RECORDS WHICH THEY ARE ALSO
ARGUING.
>> YOU HAVE TO ARGUE THESE AS
ONE BECAUSE AS THEY AFFECT THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH, THEY ARE NOT
THE SIX SEPARATE HEARINGS.
YOU HAVE TO RESPOND TO THIS
AVALANCHE OF SUBPOENAS WITH
MEANS IF YOU CLOSE DOWN SHOP.
>> Laura: A FORMER OFFICIAL
SAYS THAT THE WHITE HOUSE HAS
THE ASSERTION THAT CONGRESS DOES
NOT HAVE A RIGHT TO THE
INFORMATION.
THIS IS JOSHUA GALT'S ARE AREN'T
INTERESTS, THEY ARE CORE
RESPONSIBILITIES AT THE HEART OU
RESPONSIBILITIES AT THE HEART OR
BRANCH CHECKING OUR BRANCH AND
EVEN JUST UNDERSTANDING IT.
HOW DO YOU REACT?
>> I THINK BOTH SIDES HAVE A
PROBLEM, I THINK THE SUBPOENAS
HAVE BEEN GROSSLY OVERBROAD FROM
THE HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES AND
I THINK THE LETTER FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL IS VERY
OVERBROAD.
THERE IS NO SUCH THING AS SAYING
CONSTITUTIONALLY, YOU DON'T GET
TO DO A DO OVER AND
CONGRESSIONAL AUTHORITY TO
INVESTIGATE IS VERY BROAD.
THESE BATTLES HAVE GONE BACK
THROUGH THE BEGINNING OF THE
REPUBLIC.
GO BACK TO 1796, CONGRESS WANTED
PRESIDENT WASHINGTON'S PAPERS
AND HE SAID YOU'RE NOT GOING TO
GET THEM.
MS. MADISON SAID, HE WAS A
CONGRESSMAN, WE HAVE A RIGHT TO
DO ANYTHING WE ASK FOR IT BUT
THE PRESIDENT HAS A RIGHT TO SAY
I DON'T WANT TO GIVE IT TO YOU
AND THIS IS PART OF THE CHECKS
AND BALANCES.
>> Laura: WE WILL HAVE THE
EXECUTIVE ON TO SOMETHING THE
LEFT IS SAYING.
THERE IS A PIECE SAYING, THEY
ARE TRYING TO SAY THEY HAVE A
DIVINE RIGHT TO THE INFORMATION.
THEY ARE ALWAYS JOCKEYING FOR
POWER.
YOU REMEMBER THIS.
IT IS ALWAYS A FIGHT BETWEEN THE
LEGISLATIVE BRANCH OF THE
EXECUTIVE.
I'VE NEVER SEEN IT LIKE I SEE IT
NOW.
AT EVERY TURN THEY'VE HOUNDED
HIM AT EVERY TURN AND ACCUSED
HIM OF BEING A TRAITOR.
SETTING UP MEETINGS AT
TRUMP TOWER.
HE IS LIKE A COMBO OF STALIN AND
CHAIRMAN MAO OR SOMETHING.
THIS IS THE LEVEL.
I WANT TO PLAY SOMETHING THAT
JERRY NADLER SAID TONIGHT.
LET'S WATCH.
>> WE ARE LOOKING AT ALL OPTIONS
TO DEAL WITH A LAWLESS
ADMINISTRATION AND EVERYTHING IS
BEING LOOKED AT.
>> EVERYTHING IS BEING LOOKED AT
INCLUDING POSSIBLE JAIL?
>> WE ARE LOOKING AT THE LAW BUT
WE WILL LOOK AT ALL OPTIONS TO
FORCE THE ADMINISTRATION TO BE
ABLE TO HOLD THE ADMINISTRATION
ACCOUNTABLE, WHATEVER IT
MAY TAKE.
>> Laura: THAT WAS AT CNN.
WHAT IS HE TALKING ABOUT?
WHAT ARE THE REMEDIES?
DOES HE WANT TO ARREST SOMEBODY?
>> LET ME RESPOND WITH A
ARTICULATE COMMENT.
I THINK HE IS SAYING HE WOULD
LOOK AT JAIL WHICH IS OF COURSE
ABSURD, THERE IS NOTHING
LAWLESS.
HE COULD BE QUITE RIGHT THAT
IT'S A BROAD RESPONSE YOU KNOW
AS A LAWYER WHO RAISED ALL YOUR
ARGUMENTS AND THERE ARE SOME
BETTER OVERBROAD AND SOME THAT
ARE VERY STRONG.
THE STRONGEST ONE BEING THAT THE
COURT HELD THAT THE POWER OF THE
CONGRESS IS VERY BROAD, BUT NOT
UNLIMITED.
I THINK GIVEN THE NUMBER OF
SUBPOENAS AND HEARINGS, THE
PREDETERMINED POSITION OF THE
THREE CHAIRMAN WHO HAVE ALREADY
SAID HE SHOULD BE IMPEACHED AND
JERRY NADLER WAS OVERHEARD
BLAMING IT ON AMTRAK.
I THINK THEY HAVE A VERY GOOD
ARGUMENT TO THE COURT, HOW DO
THINGS GET THIS FAR AND LET'S
CHECK THIS, AS LONG AS THEY ARE
WILLING TO COMPROMISE.
IF THERE'S GOING TO BE A NARROW,
MORE FOCUSED SUBPOENA.
>> Laura: HE LEFT TO THE DOOR
OPEN.
HE KNOWS THAT.
IT DOES NOT LIKE HE IS SHUTTING
THE DOOR COMPLETELY.
>> IT'S NOT LAWLESS, WE WILL GO
BEFORE A COURT.
>> Laura: THEY DON'T WANT
IMPEACHMENT.
>> THAT IS WHY HE IS FULL OF YOU
KNOW WHAT.
>> Laura: DISCUSSED WHAT WE
WERE TALKING ABOUT LAST WEEK.
THERE IS A BREWING FIGHT BETWEEN
BRENNAN AND COMEY WHEN IT COMES
TO THE USE OF THIS PHONY DOSSIE
DOSSIER.
>> A DISPUTE OVER WHETHER FORMER
CA DIRECTOR JOHN BRENNAN OR
FORMER FBI DIRECTOR JAMES COMEY
PUSH THE DOSSIER DURING THE
TRANSITION HAS BROKEN OUT INTO
THE OPEN.
THE RECORDS ARE NOT PUBLIC BUT
SOURCES FROM ONLY WITH THE
CONTENT SAY THE EMAILS INDICATE
COMEY TOLD SUBORDINATES THAT HE
INSISTED THE DOSSIER SHOULD BE
INCLUDED IN THE FORMER
INTELLIGENCE ASSESSMENT ON
RUSSIAN ELECTION INTERFERENCE.
>> Laura: I'M HEARING THAT ONE
OF THOSE COMMUNICATIONS ALSO
SAYS THAT JIM COMEY AND DECEMBER
OF 2016 SAID THE DOSSIER IS
UNRELIABLE.
HE DIDN'T WANT THE INTEL TO
REVIEW IT.
I HEARD TODAY FROM A WHITE HOUSE
FORCE SAYING, THE PRESIDENT MAY
BE LOOKING TO RELEASE AND
DECLASSIFY ALL OF THE RELEVANT
DOCUMENTS LEADING OUT TO THE
PROBE NEXT WEEK.
>> I HEARD HE WILL GIVE THEM TO
BILL BARR.
I'VE BEEN HEARING THAT FOR A
LONG TIME.
>> Laura: APPARENTLY IT'S NEXT
WEEK, THAT'S WHAT MY SOURCE
TELLS ME.
THAT WILL GIVE US A LOT OF
ANSWERS.
HE WANTS THAT YOUR DEBATING.
WE WILL HAVE FACTS ON THE TABLE.
>> HE ADMITS IN HIS OWN BOOK
THAT HE DIDN'T REVEAL THE WHOLE
DOSSIER TO THE PRESIDENT, ONLY
THE SALACIOUS PARTS.
HE DIDN'T TELL HIM THIS WAS AN
INVESTIGATION AND THAT'S IN HIS
OWN BOOK.
I DON'T WANT TO SPECULATE AMONG
THOSE TWO WHICH ONE IS RIGHT.
>> Laura: APPARENTLY THERE WAS
SOME TALK ABOUT HOW THIS WOULD
LOOK, THIS COULD LOOK LIKE AMONG
INTEL SOURCES, IT COULD LOOK
LIKE THE FBI WAS DOING SOME KIND
OF WEIRD PREEMPTIVE BLACKMAIL
WITH THE PRESIDENT WITH COMEY
GOING TO THAT MEETING.
IT DIDN'T LOOK GOOD.
THEY WERE WORRIED WITH COMEY
PRESENTING THE DOSSIER WOULD
LOOK LIKE HE WAS HAVING SOME
J. EDGAR HOOVER TACTICS.
THAT IS REALLY DISTURBING.
>> IT DOESN'T LOOK LIKE IT, IT
WAS.
THE REALITY IS THAT COMEY, THE
NOOSE IS TIGHTENING AROUND HIS
NECK REALLY BAD.
HE IN JANUARY TOLD THE PRESIDENT
OF SALACIOUS AND UNVERIFIED.
HOW DID IT BECOME THAT OVER FIVE
MONTHS?
COMEY SAYS THAT IT'S VERIFIED IN
FOOTNOTE FIVE PAGE 15, HE SAYS
IT IS RELIABLE, NOT UNVERIFIED.
HE EITHER LIED TO THE PRESIDENT
OR HE LIED TO THE COURT.
I'M BETTING ON HE LIED TO THE
COURT AND WE CALL THAT PERJURY.
>> Laura: THANK YOU.
>> I WILL BELIEVE IT WHEN I SEE
IT.
>> I AGREE, IT'S HARD TO INDICT
THAT.
>> Laura: IT WILL GET VERY
INTERESTING NEXT WEEK.
>> THIS GUY WILL TELL YOU WHAT